go ahead
oh yeah this makes you want to [ __ ]
oh man you want to [ __ ] to this
absolutely want to [ __ ] do this
definitely lay pipe to this
[Music]
there it is folks holy [ __ ] there it is
that's the full version man
wow dude wow
shout out roy burns for that yo that was
amazing
holy [ __ ] yeah he killed that
dude i want to use that as our intro
song when we walk
into the new studio oh my god we should
god dude
that's so good larry we have to use that
when we walk into the new studio
[Laughter]
holy we do have a confession though
we did we had that made yeah that was
made that was created by uh
roy burns shadow roy burns man yeah
shout out roy burns that was incredible
brown brown brown wow that was sexy dude
i was feeling it
wow yeah that song you definitely want
to [ __ ] to that song
oh yeah i don't know how roy it really
sounds like that would have been the
full version of that
yeah i don't know how roy made it like
that would make me want to jack off with
the tuxedo on
yeah like this like james bond would
yeah
that felt like great gatsby or something
no yeah definitely more james bond
yeah that's the destination like he's
with the he's with the bond girl at the
craps table
mm-hmm and then he goes to the bathroom
and jerks off that's what i feel like
yeah or or that's the song that plays
when husbands are jerking off while
their wife is home
and they're walking around with their
[ __ ] a hard penis like a pistol
like a silencer and they gotta make it
to the guest bathroom yeah you gotta
make it to the guest bathroom without
being caught
[Music]
get the incognito link up on their phone
slide in the pocket
[Music]
changing outfits to be other people in
the house to get to the guest bathroom
i'm the plumber i heard there was a tube
broken in the guest bathroom
oh man that was good man that was
you definitely want to [ __ ] to that man
[ __ ] we didn't talk about justin
bieber's car dude oh
speaking of spending your [ __ ] money
in stupid-ass ways
i liked it you don't like it um i mean
it's cool it's just
[ __ ] dumb
[Laughter]
why is it dumb i just i've never
uh i understand luxury
but i've never understood taking a
luxury car
and doing a whole bunch of modifications
like that to it like when i think
modifying a car
you just like improve it so it can like
do something better not to just
i don't know turn it to a hot wheels car
it's cool
he's clearly wild to drop what a quarter
million dollars on a car like that and
just rebuild it
yeah it looks nothing like they used
nothing they took all the [ __ ] off
yeah they like refabricated parts for
[Laughter]
a bunch of [ __ ] money and then now
you just have like this
toaster car
this looks like something that silver
surfer would drive yeah
it's cool man i don't i think it's cool
i just can't get over like the capped
off wheels
you know man i i will say hats off to
justin for
creating like you know a 1950s retro
future concept of a car and driving that
[ __ ] around
this is like definitely what they
thought the future looked like in 1920
yeah yes you're right
you're definitely right and actually you
know what i'm going to give justin even
one step further and say he's actually
ahead of the curve because uh
you know covered wheels i think that's
my big prediction covered wheels is
about to be the hot [ __ ]
in 2023. so invest invest in
covered wheels everyone you heard you
heard the man yeah this is the
prediction and we always [ __ ]
participate that comes true on this
podcast so
i'm bullish on cover tales man you know
what makes me say that is
formula one is actually moving to that
and it wouldn't surprise me if like
mercedes and
other probably mercedes first start
gets figures out some weird benefit from
covered wheels and they're like all
right
we're going to release a car with
covered wheels and then it'll just you
know oh yeah
stupid-ass trend that takes off i don't
know i'm a [ __ ] idiot i don't know
what i'm talking about ever
neither do i do i just regurgitate what
i hear from other stuff
you know and other people that are
smarter than me
yeah i just um but i will say this
i did own a crypto kitty when they first
came out so that's proof
yeah i do what's it worth don't have
it's got to be worth a decent amount
no i think i just had like one of this
basic
i i bought like the least valuable one
and i think it's
still let's see let me check
we can end after this because i have to
fix my [ __ ] delay
there we go my kitties okay
oh damn i got one two three i have four
kitties
nice what are they worth man
i got a gen okay let's see what my gen
10 is worth
luke is asking if you forgot to feed her
neopets
how do i see how much this thing's worth
dude you're gonna find out you're like a
[ __ ]
crypto kitty millionaire right now
that would be so dope if we're live on
the podcast you're like i have i have a
[ __ ] million dollars
okay you know what i'm i gotta i gotta
do more research into what this one's
actually like
or what this one's actually worth so i
have four of them though that's pretty
cool
all right let's find it out for the
moment anyways